[Música]
[Aplausos]
o lado sobe que falar que sejam muito
bem vindos mais um vídeo e como você
está vendo hoje é dia 31 de outubro
portanto feridas bruxas ou em grupo e é
claro muitos álbuns natal que ingressa
hoje vou citar o meu mip e vocês vão ver
estudo agora aí não esqueçam só porque
vem continuamente o que me deixa muito
mais que subscrevam bibala
ó ó ó ó ó ó ó
[Música]
o dólar a cair vamos lá pessoal mais um
susto tem que está errado com meu deus
que vem explodindo de campos que vou
fazer vou deixar a câmera aqui porque
entretanto comendas estava então vou
deixar de tudo o que era
[Música]
foi o que eu fiz
[Aplausos]
[Música]
o projeto de ter cuidado com o lixo
fui saber em qual posição com destaque
do lobisomem não tenta esconder dentro
do corpo deu o aval muito gosto dele
[Música]
ó
deixam rondônia não quer evitar o uso só
pra constar como está daqui do vídeo de
hoje como está o meu amigo no haloween
bill sexual se que o vídeo foi bem
rápido foi bem curto mas foi um vídeo
totalmente experimental a equipe nada
disto estava planeado eu tive que fazer
tudo assim de improviso e ficará super
cup fãs prostituas certo e teve que
fazer este vídeo só nesta manhã até por
ainda estar hoje que é longo então foi
um vídeo mesmo muito experimental mas se
vocês apoiarem muitos filhos deixarem
muito lhe que mesmo se importarem com os
nossos amigos e eu aí posso fazer mesma
seria como estar um amigo e faz coisas
mesmo muito e as tipo imagine eu fingir
uma porção o contratado até mesmo alguém
que foi na casa sua própria estátua mil
da pvc muita coisa então é só achei
muito bom e espero mesmo que tenham
estado eo tem muitas ficam bem engraçado
mas espero que vocês gostem fiquem bem e
até aproximar